Eric give me your reaction with these
comments we are hearing from Alexis
tsipras he's asking his people to vote
no but he's also saying i'm not actually
daring the creditors to kick us out of
the eurozone well that's what he wants
everybody to believe he's finished
speaking Olivia just moments ago and
just to put it into perspective to try
to characterize for everybody what he is
the kind of posture if you will that
he's taking this is not the alexis
tsipras that international investors
wanted to see it's not the Alexis
tsipras that moderate European
politicians and lenders wanted to see
because he has struck the kind of
defiant tone that he struck on Monday
and saying in addition to continuing the
news I suppose the headline if you will
is that the referendum is going forward
as scheduled on Sunday and as you
pointed out he is urging Greeks to vote
no which is to say to reject the bailout
proposal from Greece's European
creditors he says it's not about the
euro and this is really the fulcrum if
you will on which the whole debate is
rocking back and forth is the referendum
about euro membership or not about euro
membership the yes vote the yes campaign
wants Greek people to believe that it is
about euro membership and there's good
reason to believe that it is because
that's how its interpreted back in
Brussels for example and Berlin but
Alexis tsipras says it is not about euro
membership he says that Europe is to
blame for shutting Greeks banks by
limiting the liquidity assistance
available to the financial system he
says syriza his party is fighting for
Greek pensions and this is where it gets
a little bit interesting assures the
Greek people that their pensions and
their deposits in Greek banks won't be
lost how he is able to offer such an
assurance i think is an open question
for you to you end and for me and i
can't answer it but nevertheless he's
making that promise to people he says
it's because Greece will be in a
stronger negotiating position come
Monday after this no vote that he's
campaigning for effectively forcing
creditors back to the table to offer
Greece a better deal again
given what we've heard from Angela
Merkel from Wolfgang Schauble Merkel
spoke moments ago said she's still open
to a deal with Greece but certainly not
on any better terms it's really
difficult to see how mr. tsipras the
Prime Minister can make these kinds of
promises Olivia and Eric this really is
a fast-moving situation so tsipras is
speaking of the building behind you
right there you mentioned that Merkel
was just being there you see Matteo
Renzi the lyric Italy speaking he is at
that press conference with Chancellor
Merkel I'll just read you some of the
headlines coming from Matteo Renzi he
actually says the Greek referendum is a
mistake he says it's an error but he
will respect the Greek people's will he
says it's unthinkable that Italy and
other governments are going to fund
Greek pensions without reform he says we
can't afford Greek shipbuilders that
don't actually pay taxes again he's
commenting to reporters in Berlin after
this meeting that he had had with
Chancellor Merkel Eric going to get back
to you actually on the banking situation
particular one of the things I've been
trying to figure out is exactly how the
ECB is going to respond to all of this
whether or not they are actually going
to cut Greece some more slack extend the
ELA the emergency liquidity assistance
how far away do you think we are from
seeing a big Greek bank run well it's
it's impossible for a bank run to happen
because the banks are closed and people
are limited to 60 euros a day of ATM
withdrawals and the pensioners are
limited 220 euros a week of withdrawals
in person from the banks that started
today so Greece has taken steps to
forestall a bank run to perhaps answer
your question in a different way it's
more a matter of whether these banks are
ever going to be able to open again
remember that because the bailout ended
last night and because Greece missed its
payment to the IMF these banks are
effectively technically if you will
insolvent already that's going to make
it awfully difficult for them to reopen
as the government has promised on Monday
regardless of the referendum result
there are there is speculation if you
will going around Athens right now that
it's going to be weeks before the banks
reopen some people have even said to me
it's quite possible they'll never be
able to reopen in their current form
it's far too early to speculate on that
level but it is fair to say that it
would be exceedingly difficult for the
government to try and reopen these banks
today or tomorrow or even monday at this
point